[Musique]
et donc les diplômés de 2020 deux sont
aujourd'hui réunis une dernière fois
après trois ou quatre années
agroparistech il nous sommes plusieurs à
ne pas vouloir faire mine d'être fiers
et méritante d'obtenir ce diplôme à
l'issue d'une formation qui pousse
globalement à participer aux ravages
sociaux et écologiques en cours nous ne
nous considérons pas comme les talents
d'une planète soutenable nous ne voyons
pas les ravages écologiques et sociaux
comme des enjeux ou des défis auxquels
nous devons trouver des solutions en
tant qu'ingénieur nous ne croyons pas
que nous avons besoin de toutes les
agricultures nous voyons plutôt que
l'agro industrie mène une guerre aux
vivants et à la paysannerie partout sur
terre nous voyons plutôt que nous ne
voyons pas les sciences et techniques
comme neutre et apolitique
nous pensons que l'innovation
technologique ou les start up ne savons
rien d'autre que le capitalisme nous ne
croyons ni au développement durable ni à
la croissance verte ni à la transition
écologique une expression qui
sous-entend que la société pourra
devenir soutenable sans qu'on se
débarrasse de l'ordre social dominant
agroparistech
[Applaudissements]
agroparistech forme chaque année des
centaines d'élèves a travaillé pour
l'industrie de diverses manières trafic
et en labo des plantes pour des
multinationales qui renforce
l'asservissement des agricultrices et
des agriculteurs concevoir des plats
préparés et ensuite des chimiothérapie
pour soigner les maladies causées
inventer des labels bonne conscience
pour permettre aux cadres de se croire
héroïque en mangeant mieux que les
autres développer des hernies des
énergies dites vertes qui permettent
d'accélérer la numérisation de la
société tout en polluant et en
exploitant à l'autre bout du monde
pondre des rapports rse d'autant plus
long et délirant que les crimes qu'il
masque sont scandaleux ou encore compter
des grenouilles et des papillons pour
que les bétonneurs puisse les faire
disparaître légalement ces jobs sont
destructeurs et les choisir c'est nuire
en servant les intérêts de quelques-uns
c'est pourtant ses débouchés qui nous
ont été présentés tout au long de notre
cursus agroparistech en revanche on ne
nous a jamais parlé de des diplô me qui
considère que ces métiers font davantage
partie des problèmes que des solutions
et qui ont choisi de déserter
[Applaudissements]